and do you know why I say that because
the reason why I'm happy that I got is
because like I said I proved to myself
that if I work hard I can get results so
my mental power has increased yeah we
don't give a [__] but you should give a
[__] no why should I do not worry about
this [__] no do you know why you should
give a [__] because when your children
are in school and they need support from
the parent and you're out there working
it's going to be me that's going to
happen are you going to be the teachers
when a kid when a kid comes to me says
Mommy I need help with the homework
Daddy's at work who's going to help
mommy so I shall clap for you that if my
kid comes
I just have a question what